Hey guys,  I'm Nate, I'm out here in the desert with Stuart edge, and we've got our paintball gun tanks
And we're ready to start driving and shooting at each other
Building these things was super fun
And it would not have happened if it were not for our sponsor World of Tanks
Check out the link in the promo code in the description
Oh
Building the second of these tanks took me almost
16 hours to complete and it only went that fast because on the first tank I had figured out how to do everything
She may assumes that I'm just like a shoot shoot shoot shoot, no I precisely time my shots I could go like days
That's right good cuz you're never doing behind my take to shoot my tank you're never gonna get a single
All I see is this
That's all I got here. Is that love that love line. Hey, let's go
Coming for you coming up behind you fast better run ride no
I
Just realized something we're down here at the same level of these paintball guns
We are should probably go and I think we might get shot fits pretty. Yeah, let's take the hill
Oh-ho-oh all right, that's it you're going down you're going down you're going down
You're gonna hit a rock I'm just gonna roll right over
Rude
I'm coming
Oh
All right go go go
Don't go there don't go over there oh
He's survived coming back coming back you're not going down that easy
Take day, I'm
Pretty sure that even with the frame the loaded paintball gun and the foam body on these tanks
They're still hitting almost 25 miles an hour
Oh
I
Tilled it I shot it. Take it it died. That's what happens with tanks right you shoot him and they just die
Take it that'll be great even with your car flipping in the other day
Look at this look you nailed
My well actually you nailed the GoPro attached to my tank
Splattered the paintball tank, and then you physically ran into my tank and Phil oh
I had to sacrifice my tank to get that shot
But it was well worth it and right here on the hopper on the GoPro all right. That's it
These things are actually really fun
These cars are killer having a paintball gun have you ever driven anything that you can drive and shoot before no?
I think this is a first for me. Yeah. They look realistic. It's fun
Especially when you're like a little ways away from yours like oh, it's just like a tank just traveling over the little desert scenery
It's kind of trippy cuz you think you're looking at like a huge tank off in the distance and you're super far away a bit
And then you realize that most tanks probably can't spin out the way that these ones do yeah?
It's pretty hard to actually hit someone's tank but
It's really entertaining this project has been a ton of fun. Thank you to Stuart for being the
Co-pilot, I don't know. What do you call the person who drives a tank?
It's a tank east
tanker I
Can't be right anyway
Also a huge shout-out to our sponsor for this video World of Tanks
World of Tanks is a free online game that throws players into epic tank battles across
Incredible battlefields you can work as a team you take part in joint operations
You can engage and head-to-head duels that feel like any other co-op shooting game as a reminder if you sign up now using the code
Ww2 tanks you can get 3 days of premium play 500 gold and a free premium tank
Check the link in the description below for more details
Hey guys
Thanks for watching if you're not a subscriber yet hit the bomb to get in the club if you missed our last video or you?
Want to watch it again click up here at the top
Click down there if you want to see what the internet thinks you should watch next that's it for now have fun
Be safe. See you tomorrow